welcome back to 8701
so we are going to start a new chapter
in this class feinman calculus
the purpose of this very first
introduction is to just set
the stage and we do this by recapping
what we'll discuss so far in the first
three weeks of this course
so first we introduce the player in the
field the elementary particles the meta
particles and the force carriers
um we have seen that there is
regeneration of fermions
that has leptons and quarks we have seen
that they
in principle interact in different ways
um
with those force carriers we have seen
that there are three kinds of charges or
three kinds of
interactions um the electromagnetic
interaction
the weak interaction and the strong
interaction
um then we moved on and had a
qualitative a quantitative discussion of
relativistic kinematics
uh so there's quite a set of useful
problems we can look at
for example we're wondering how much
energy does my approacher need in a beam
on a fixed target where we want to
produce anti-protons
so those problems we were able to
discuss and quantitatively figure out
what the answer's answers to those
questions are
then we looked at fireman diagram we are
able to you know read them and
understand what they principally mean
and then we had a discussion last week
on symmetries we introduced parity
we introduced charge conjugation we
looked at cp
and cp violation we had a qualitative
discussion on the case in scattering
uh we defined what a geometrical cross
section is
and now we are really starting the
quantitative discussion of particle
dynamics
we do this now in the next video by
introducing femi's
golden rule and then we
study a toy theory which is simplified
such that
the algebra involved is not going to be
too much of a hustle
so we can focus on understanding or
following
findman rules in order to calculate the
k rates and scattering cross sections